abone ol
12 metresi
bu iklim krizi küresel tehdit
biz bunları son dönemlerde çok fazla
duyuyoruz hepiniz Bunlar kadar fazla
olmasada çözüm yöntemleri ve çözüm
önerilerini de çok fazla buluyoruz Peki
hukuk bu çözümün neresinde ha
3D hukukta çözüm noktasını kim
meselesine ve iklim değişikliğine çözüm
noktasında nasıl yararlanabiliriz
abone ol
Eğer bu soruya cevap verebilmemiz için
hastalığın cevaplamamız gereken çok daha
temel bir soru var bu hukuk niçin kim
için
10 ya cevabını da çok farklı görüşler
bilir sürebilir var Ancak hiç kenar
görüş daha hakim olarak ortaya çıkar
Ne mutlu söyle sizi
bu daha iyi bir hayat daha iyi bir dünya
için hukuk yolundan gidilmesi
gerektiğini altı çizilir bir ara
ve hukuk
ve adalet Barış dayanışma Semanur
üzerinde
bu topik yanı olan ancak bu temalar
üzerinden diğerleri vurgu yapan bir yana
sağlıktır dolayısıyla da bu görüş
birçoğumuzun da aklından çoğu zaman
geçmiştir ancak bir de ikinci bir görüş
var ki
Sen bugün işte özellikle canım müziği
olmayan toplumlarda
hukuk Güçlünün yanında yer aldığı gücün
yanında yer aldığı dolayısıyla da
zayıfın korunması anlamından çıkıp
gücünün korunması ve daha fazla gücün
güçlüye verilmesi şeklinde de
tanımlanabilir Ancak bu çok Aslında
pratikte
hukuk tarafı Kur'an sınırlanabilir şiir
dolayısıyla da hukukun aslında Hem gücün
aracı olabilmek hem de diğer taraftan
vücut sınırla ya bilme batıkları vardır
O halde bizim hangi yolu seçmemiz
gerekir hangi yoldan etmemiz gerekir
yani Güçlü'den ve gücünün korunması
yolundan mı yoksa sınıf
Bu nasıl Yolunda
ve bu tır o
insanın seçimleri ve tercihleri de verir
insan seçimleri ve tercihleriyle O
yollardan hangisini seçeceğini belirler
Ve beni çok başka mesele de olduğu gibi
Aslında iklim değişikliği meselesinde de
durum aynıdır
Özellikle bu kokusal yetersizlikler yani
hukukun mevcut sistemindeki
yetersizlikler ve problemler bir tarafta
okusa yetersizlikler Diğer taraftan
iklim değişikliğinin kendisinden
kaynaklı birlikte özellikler ne yazikki
Mevcut durumda acil halinde birazcık
diyet durumunu ortaya çıkarır
o biliyor musunuz Bu kul çözümün bir
parçası yapabiliriz
özellikle çevre ve serilerinde iki
değişikliği gibi konularda
presel işbirliğini Çok ciddi bir önemi
vardır küresel işbirliği her düz ne
düzeyde sağlanması gerekir Kredi
işbirliğinin sağlanması yeterlidir
hukukun bir çözüm aracı olabilmesi için
yeterli değildir Bu işlerini ulusal
yerel düzeylerde uygulanabilir hale
gelmesi gerekir Peki bu yeterlidir Bu da
yeterli değildir Tüm bu süreçleri
davranışsal değişikliği dönüşebilmesi
gerekmektedir be çok daha önemli bir
konu vardır ki hukukun Etkin olabileceği
çok gereksiz profil hukuk uygulamaları
hu hu hu mevcut olabilir genel olarak
bir sarar ya da gir problem olduğunda
ona cevap veren ve artık bir
pozisyondadır
ancak çevresel meselelerde kim
değişikliği gibi meselelerde hukukun
aynı zamanda bu Aktif olması da
gerekmektedir yani sadece mevcut bir
vaka sorun olduğunda ona cevap veren
konumunda değil aynı zamanda Oha Tamam
adına gelmeden zararlı da gelmeden önlem
alabilecek noktada olması gerekir Bu
yeterli midir Ay aynı zamanda posta
Aktif olması gerekir yani mevcut durun
olmadan önemini alıyor önce mevcut durum
meydana geldikten sonra karşı bir cevap
veriyor ve bu durumu ya dedesi geriye
iadesi yada zararın tazminini noktasında
birtakım
mekanizmalar geliştirebilecek vasıflara
ne oluyor işte bu durumda ancak hukuk o
yapbozun bir parçası çok da önemli bir
parçası Hatta Merkezi noktada olabilir
aynı zamanda hukukun çok daha önemli bir
baskı daha var o nedir peki o da Adalet
duygusudur
Sen neden olabilir iklim değişikliği
meselesinde de çevresel meselelerde de
hukukun diğer aktif olabileceği
meselelerde adalet duygusu neden
önemlidir Çünkü herhangi bir yerdeki
adaletsizlik
ve her yerde ki diğer her yerdeki Adalet
duygusunu azaltabilir aşağıya çekebilir
Ben de bundan dolayı da aslında hukuku
mekanizmaları doğru ve Etkin uygulanması
pratikte çok çok önemlidir
Pir hukukun Etkin uygulanması ve adalet
duygusu özellikle ikili konularında
günümüzde nasıl ortaya çıkmaktadır
özellikle toplumları iklim davaların
yoluyla son modelleri konuda çok ciddi
bir hassasiyet gösterdiğini görmekteyiz
Örneğin boynuna doğru genelde da varsın
Fransa'da yüzyılında sı Avrupa Birliği
kapsamındaki halkın kimi davası bunları
bize göstermektedir yine Amerika'daki
iklim değişikliği gençlerin gençlikleri
değişikliği davası pek çok başka davalar
sayılabilir belli raporlarına göre de
zaten bu davaların sayısı bine
yaklaşmıştır bu kadar yıldır Peki Hayır
özellikle son dönemde Uluslararası
kuruluşların da O çok ciddi kararları
olduğunu konularda görüyoruz deri
Güvenlik Konseyi gibi bir organın Kemal
ne yaptığını görüyoruz iklim değişikliği
ile ilgili yine bu sayede ceza
mahkemesini Eko Kırım suçunun tartışmaya
başladığını görüyoruz çok yakın dönemde
demeyi sanatları komitesini çevre
hakkının evrensel bir hap olarak
tanımlayabileceğimiz önünde
görüşebilirsiniz görüyoruz yine deme
çocuk hakları komitesi'nin konuya
ilişkin birtakım başvurular aldığını
görüyoruz ve bunlar gerçekten çok çok
önemli
gelişmeler benim tüm bu gelişmeler ve
toplumları halkları bu konudaki
hassasiyetinin gelişmesi bu konuda hukuk
araştırmaları iki dağlara ya da bu
kararlar yüzünde başvurmaları nedir
zaferi göstergesidir neresi değil
Ben hiçbir zaman göstergesi değildir ama
yetersizliklerin göstergesidir Bir de
hukukta Aslında yetersiz göstererek t&o
adalet ve barış duygularına değerlere
vurgu yapması anlamında yine de
önemlidir ve anlamlıdır bilimleri
zaferler ya da bu konuda ciddi soru
çözümleri için ne yapılmalıdır başka
söylediğimiz noktaya geliyoruz ile insan
ve insanın seçimleri tercihleri
yaşanabilir bir dünya için de
Sürdürülebilir bir dünya için de bu
Hukukun üstünlüğü hukukun Sürdürülebilir
içinde
bir insanın seçimleri ve tercihleri çok
oldu
bu biri bu seçimleri yaparken insan
ve bu seçimleri yaparken
kendinize herkesi insan Merkezi olmaya
devam mı edecek
gidiyoruz insan Merkezi
olurken bile insana zarar verebilecek
kararlar alabiliyoruz ne yazık ki
Ben bu şekilde devam ederse yeni kendi
şelasyonu muz hem de gelecek şeyle
rasyonlar için acaba doğru bir şey
yapmaya devam edebilecek miyiz İnsan
bu hukuku bir çözüm aracı yapabilmesi
için öncelikli olarak Eko sistemin
bütünü bütün üzerinden düşünmesi ve
hukuk mekanizmalarını da buna göre
kurgulaması ve uygulaması gerekiyor
ancak
çok acil vurumu hemen şimdi durumu söz
konusu ve bu aciliyet halinde acziyeti
yeşil acziyeti yaşamaması için insanın
bir an önce bu seçimlerini aynı zamanda
uygulamaya koyması gerekiyor Dolayısıyla
insan tercihleri ve seçimleriyle pek çok
Başka konuda olduğu gibi aslına
bakarsanız iklim değişikliği konusunda
da merkezde hukukun seçimi noktasında da
Merkezi insan seçimleriyle yolunu
belirliyor ve
seçimleri insanın gerçekten çok önemli
bu nedenlerini seçimleri insanın Çünkü
seçtiğimiz hukuk yolunu geleceğimizi
bilir
bir de